-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning actor
you know from movies
such as "The Birdcage"
and shows like "Ray Donovan,
"Brockmire,"
and his three decades-long run
on "The Simpsons."
He is the host of
"The Jim Brockmire Podcast,"
with episodes available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Hank Azaria.
How are you, Hank?
-Hello, Seth.
Nice to see you.
We're both in our casual
button-down shirts
with sleeves rolled up.
This is a dream come true
really.
-It's not bad. I --
-No.
-I want to talk to you about
how you figured out
working from home,
but I also enjoy talking to yo
about baseball and the Mets.
We're talking right now,
the Mets are above .500.
I know it's early,
but how are you feeling?
-Yeah, well, cautious.
I'm feeling cautious, Seth
I'm very used to getting
my heart broken.
Something usually goes
terribly wrong, as we know
As Jim Brockmire likes to say,
"the Mets are the Yankees
of not being the Yankees."
But right now --
Well, the Yankees are so bad
that that's actually working
in the Mets' favor.
But I -- You know,
you have a nagging feeling
that the universe
will right itself
and the Yankees
will start winning
and the Mets will fall apart
in some new and amazing way.
My money is on
Bernie Madoff's ghost
doing a reverse, like, "Angels
in the Outfield" kind of thing
-It'd be nice to get Berni
back involved with the team.
I know he had a special
connection with them
over the years.
-Yeah, he's been great
to all Mets fans.
Just like his -- It was like his
specter will shove Jacob deGro
and, like, pick up an outfielder
and replace him with Tim Tebow
or something.
-You -- I -- You know,
this is such a nice outcom
for your character Jim Brockmire
because, as we've talked before,
he sort of started as a voic
before he became anything
that we could see.
And, so, now he is back to
being a voice on a podcast
You must enjoy the real estate
that a podcast allows you
to have with this incredible
character you created.
-I do.
[As Jim] Any excuse to continu
to talk this way, Seth,
is good news for me.
This is the generic baseball
announcer voice of the 1970s
that is also
Jim Brockmire's voice.
[Normal voice]
You know, it really --
This podcast grew out of the way
we promoted the show
over the years
even before it was a series.
I'd go on "The Rich Eisen Show
as Brockmire
and all these ESPN shows,
and they're fun to go on
because you get a very
knowledgeable sports commentator
giving an informed take
on whatever story of the day
and then Brockmire would come in
and give his take.
And it was like putting
a drunk conspiracy theoris
on "Meet the Press"
or something.
And he has real sports opinions,
but they're insane,
and giving him a platform
is fairly irresponsible.
But, you know,
it worked as promotion,
so we figured
why not reverse it?
-You -- You have a lot
of wonderful guests.
Your first guest was someone
who is maybe as outlandish
as the fictional character
of Jim Brockmire,
and that person
was Charles Barkley.
Was that as enjoyable to d
as it was to listen to?
-It was completely surreal
As you say,
Brockmire is outrageous,
but he always tells the truth,
Brockmire.
He's usually wasted
out of his mind
or talking about
how he was wasted.
And he says anything
on or off the air.
So most guests are a littl
kind of shocked or taken aback
by that, but Barkley
was completely immune.
And I realized
like 15 minutes in
that Barkley's more Brockmir
than Brockmire.
You know? Couldn't shock him
Whatever insane story
I told as Brockmire,
Charles had one
like twice as crazy.
And, yeah,
the interview went well.
Charles actually
genuinely opened up.
I don't think he realized
that Brockmire
was a fictional character.
And he's like, "Finally,
someone who understands
where I'm coming from
when I talk about
getting drunk and naked
and pretending to know karate,
which is a story
he actually told.
-My -- I've been lucky enoug
to spend some time with Charles.
And the best thing
about his stories,
which are all better
than my best story,
is he never tells them
like he's shocked it happened.
-No. Not at all.
-Yeah.
-A couple of the stories
he told, Seth,
if we put those out,
he'd be canceled,
I'd be canceled for listening.
You'd be canceled 'cause
I just told you about it.
It'd be like that movie
"The Ring."
Anybody who heard it would
get canceled within seven days
-He's a wonderful guy.
It was great
that you had him on.
You have a lot of great guests
And I also want
to congratulate you.
34 seasons of "The Simpsons.
-Yeah.
-You know, people say
at that point
you must be able to phone it in.
I know you don't do that insofar
as effort, but you do literall
phone it in right now
due to pandemic rules.
How has that been? There -
Do you just do it on the phone
-No.
They sent a lot of
professional equipment.
And so we do it from home now.
It's gotten easier.
But there have been times
when not only on "The Simpsons,"
but, you know, you just throw it
on the voice memo for movies
or TV shows or whatever.
And they'll forget
that it was just a voice memo,
and it will actually end u
in the show.
And, you know...
[As Chief Wiggum] "If you listen
closely to Chief Wiggum,
like, at timecode, like,
1 minute, 42 seconds,
you can actually hear
the very faint sound
of my cat vomiting
in the distance.
It's beautiful."
-Obviously, you've created
all these characters.
How many of the voices
were based on
either celebrity impressions
or people you had met
in your life up to that point?
-All of them.
All the voices are some form
of mimicry or another,
either celebrities or people
I went to college with
or grew up with or whatever.
And some are, like,
good impressions,
and some are
horrible impressions,
but either way, they make
sort of a good character voice
Sometimes I develop impression
out of, like, emotional need
Like, um...
Like, I gained a bunch of weight
about 20 years ago.
I gained like 35 pounds.
And I felt -- I felt fat.
I felt heavy
'cause I kind of was, and...
[As Marlon Brando]
"So I kind of --
I developed a Brando impressio
because I just felt
like Marlon -- Marlon Brando
And I would call, and I'm --
'Can I get an extra large
stuffed-crust
meat lover's pizza?
And someday --
and that day may never come --
I may call upon you
for a second pizza.'"
You know, stuff like that.
-You -- I always
am fascinated by the thing
that happens to people who are
very good at impressions,
is sometimes they cross path
with someone
that they've impersonated.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-You -- You actually got t
sit down with Jack Nicholson
who is someone that you were
known to have an impression of
Did he want --
Did he know you did him?
-No, he did not.
But I had tremendous, like
social anxiety that he would -
that somebody would say it
and he would ask me
for the impression.
But the thing --
I actually had to sit
next to him on a plane
for a bunch of hours.
And I was really --
I don't know --
I don't know if this ever --
I mean, your job
is you talk to --
and you have for many years --
talk to every manner
of celebrity.
I don't know if you get nervou
doing it ever still.
-I think I would get nervous
about a full flight.
You know what I mean?
That's a whole different
set of stakes.
-Yeah, you're used to
15-minute increments.
-Right.
-Yeah, so I'm really nervous
I've got to make small tal
with Jack Nicholson.
But I had no reason
to be nervous 'cause...
[As Nicholson] "Jack, I don'
know if you talked to him
or met him --
By the way, this is lately Jack.
[Softly] There's young Jac
that's kind of like this.
[Loudly]
But this is more recent Jack
And he's just happy
to talk about whatever,
and he keeps it going
and just --
You don't have to worry
about awkward pauses, Seth
'cause he'll just fill it
the hell in, God damn it."
And he has --
he has this crazy thing.
He'll reference people,
friends of his or something,
that he assumes you know,
and then he'll throw in, like,
little sayings that I can't --
couldn't tell whether they wer
literal or metaphorical like..
[As Nicholson]
"Well, you know, Seth,
it's just like Dicky D says.
You know, if it ain't
pancakes in the mornin',
nobody's pouring syrup
in the afternoon."
And you're like, "I'm sorry.
Who's Dicky D?"
[As Nicholson]
"Oh, Dicky D's my accountant
Known him for years."
"You mean literally pancakes?"
[As Nicholson] "No, yeah.
I'm saying we had breakfast.
And we wanted to have
some panc--"
I'm like, "Oh, okay."
But, you know, he doesn't --
Whether it's literal or no
or whether you ask or not,
he's happy just to keep going.
He'll explain it
or he'll just plow through
It was a delight actually.
-That is -- That is fantastic.
And I think that's a whole
different class
of impressionist
that can do the same perso
through the years.
I'm not surprised
that you are that class.
Hey, I really --
I hope I see you soon.
I know you've been doing
a lot of online
poker tournaments for charity.
I would love to find my wa
to one of those.
And just thank you so much
for being here, Hank.
-Please.
I'm going to hit you up.
I'm going to
take you up on that.
-All right.
I look forward to that.